- My eyes are down here clearly.
- You can do it, yeah.
Bras.
This is why you don't
let guys play with bras.
- What do I know about bra prices?
- They're expensive.
- They're very expensive.
- I have zero life experience
that has led me to this moment.
- But I bet we have a good time.
- Wow.
- It's got a nice wire support.
- It feels like it's gonna break.
- I feel like it would be cheap.
- This has a lot of intricate lacing.
- I'm guessing $65.
- 15 bucks.
- 20 bucks.
- I'd say $24.
- $52.
- $42.35.
- [Both] Yes!
- Ohhhh.
- $15, well what a steal.
- This looks like a really nice fancy bra.
- I guess what we learned
is I'm easily impressed.
- Oh, is this a bra?
- This one seems cheap to me.
I've seen like some nice
bralettes, this ain't one of them.
- Oh it's Free People.
- Not soft at all.
- Does this change your
opinion on how much it costs?
- No, I still think it costs less,
oh I can feel your heart beat.
- $65.
- No, $29.95.
- I'm gonna go ahead and say $30.
- It's Free People, so I'm gonna say $50.
- $26.72?
- $70.
- Oh.
- Wow you are destroying me.
- That's too much.
- Oh I was close!
- This is kind of fancy.
- I actually for some reason,
feel like this is cheap.
I would not disgrace
my boobs with this bra.
- I find that with womens clothing,
less material means more expensive.
- That fact that it's so easy to take off,
tells me that it's cheap.
- This could be like a boutique.
- I'm gonna go with $12.
- $45.
- $65.
- $60.
- $12.
- $27.
- Yeah!
- Oh you killed it.
- Woo, I was so wrong.
- Dang.
- I would never spend $60
on a pair of underwear.
But then again, all my
underwear have holes in it.
- Do you want me to
buy you some underwear?
- No, I'm okay, thanks though.
Oh yeah, this is more my style.
- Aw yeah.
- These are what we've been waiting for.
- Victoria Secret.
- This is a nice bra.
- Do you have to pay more
the bigger your boobs are?
- $22.
- $55.
- $60.
- $35.
- $112, I'm shooting for the stars.
- $89.
- Oh!
- What?
- Bras cost a whole bunch of money,
and it's kind of nonsense what costs what.
- I'm glad I don't have to buy bras.
- I feel kind of bad that
women have to spend that much.
- Yeah.
- On things that you need.
- The cheapest bra, is still
more than I've ever spent
on a single pair of boxer briefs.
- If something makes you
feel sexy to wear it,
wear it, if you don't
give a (beep) about that,
don't wear it.
Don't wear a bra at all,
I don't give a (beep).
- Do whatever you want.
- It's fine, it's your boobs.
- Yeah.
- We're just pretending
not to look at them.
Do you think I'm pulling it off?
- I think you should pull it off.
(laughing)
- You wanna help me?
- Yeah, sure.